you look a bit lonely today
should pay a visit to my brothel this
evening tell me
does someone somewhere keep your balls
in a little box
do you know i have no idea where they
are and we had been
so close a simple word to the queen
one shudders of the thought when you
find yourself in bed with an
ugly woman best close your eyes get it
over with
i must be one of the few men in this
city who doesn't want to be king
you must be one of the few men in the
city who isn't a man
you can do better than that carry on
what are you doing here i don't think
lord varys likes fish bye
how can you tell i can always tell
i plan to marry princess marcella off to
theon greyjoy
theon greyjoy me and the lads rounded up
all the known thieves
what do you want tell me
if we're going to play you'll have to
start
most men like what they see i'm not like
most men that's what most men say
allow me to return the favors
the lord of harrenhal will make a worthy
suitor for the widow aaron for which i
am extremely grateful to you
my lord lady aaron and i have known each
other since we were children
she has always been positively
predisposed
toward me a successful courtship and
they fat a lot of men we're talking
about the same podrick
quite boy in lord tyrion's service seems
a bit
simple what did he do to them
i don't know my lord they said it was
hard to describe
come everyone pick her up and carry her
to a wedding
i am the king
i killed my lover with my bare hands
i shot my own father with a crossbow
i never said you were perfect i will
not be of any use to daenerys targaryen
if i lose my mind i can't remember the
last face i saw that wasn't yours
it's
hair the mother of dragons
[Laughter]
because you have no [ __ ]
lost dragons were no larger than cats
they must be unchained or their waste
away
sunday how many times were you in the
company of these dragons
my own recent experience with slavery
has taught me the horrors of that
institution how many days were you
asleep
long enough to know not long enough to
understand
because i have voles and you don't
you